what's he doing he's making the wrong
face look who just sent me a text Addy
mallister what should I say just play it
cool welcome to the world inside your
phone where everyone is expected to act
one way their whole life a snap ow my
name is Jean and I'm supposed to be a
meh you know like meh who cares but my
problem is I have more than one emotion
check this out huh
huh son please tell me you weren't
laughing just now what if you get sent
out on the phone making the wrong face
Dad I'll make the right face then I
would finally fit
in sweetie you're so handsome when you
make that face I think he's ready
M that's our user Alex we have an
incoming text we are go for meting me
what's he doing he's making theong wrong
face huh what the heck welcome to the
loser Lounge where the Emojis who never
get used hang out what's up high
five I'm an emoji I've got to have some
sort of purpose here I'm going to help
you we need to get off the phone and
find the source code then I can fit in
let's roll Bye
Felicia you got first we have to get
through this
firewall what's Alex's girlfriend's name
again it was
Tina access denied Karen Sarah I want to
say Lupita but that doesn't feel right
now I'm saying out
loud I think you're pretty cool just the
way you
[Music]
are nobody leaves the phones delete them
my feelings are huge maybe I'm meant to
have more than just one emotion where am
I candy brush Divine sweet tasty
delicious oh I've never eaten another
piece of candy ever
again high five don't do it don't you do
it it's already been in there
once okay son what do we do after we go
potty should we wash our
hands we're number two
[Music]
I got a reply to add's text what should
I do be chill what send her an
emoji okay be
cool welcome to the secret world inside
your phone where emojis like me work and
live here each of us does one thing and
we have to nail it every time incoming
text we are go for me who me what's he
doing he's making the wrong
face what is that I've got to get this
phone
fixed this has never happened before and
now Alex has made an appointment to wipe
out his phone is Alex delet the phone
our whole world gets wiped out I'm not
going to run away from this I made a
mistake but I'm going to fix
it I think we can make things right we
just have to go to a place where no
Emoji has gone before the cloud I know a
shortcut through some apps but no one's
ever left our city and they'll send bxs
after
[Music]
us what is this place the greatest place
ever Candy Crush I've never eating
another piece of candy
again high five don't do it don't you do
it it's already been in there
once fire
yeah you've got to distract the B I've
got an
idea oh
snap we're running out of time before
the phone gets wiped we need to guess
the master password access
denied this might take a while wait what
access denied I'm fire all just we're
going to have to dance our way out
everybody can dance see
can't
[Music]
uh